j'ai enclenché quand même un certain
nombre de questions importantes et
j'entends suivent leur cheminement
jusqu'à avoir des réponses sérieuses
j'estime avoir ce qu'il faut pour
continuer à exercer un tel mandat qui
demande évidemment des compétences par
exceptionnel mais quelques compétences
quand même celle notamment de savoir
saisir un texte dit dans dans extraire
la substance le plus rapidement possible
et puis enfin j'ai tout simplement envie
que l'on que l'on nous reconnaissent en
tant qu elle que nous nous reconnaissent
je parle des ultra marins que l'on
reconnaisse comme comme n'étant pas des
gens venus d'ailleurs venu de nulle part
en tout cas et que nous avons une
identité culturelle une identité
territoriale et surtout une identité
historique et que tout cela fait de nous
des humains à part entière et des gens
qui ont des choses à défendre et à
revendiquer